[Musica]
al primo censimento italiano del
dopoguerra nel 1951 l'Italia risultava
avere 47 milioni di abitanti all'incirca
di questi 20 milioni abitavano in
pianura venti in collina e poco più di 7
abitavano in montagna
da allora A distanza di quasi tre
generazioni la popolazione italiana è
cresciuta passando da 47 milioni fino a
superare i 60 milioni qualche anno fa
con un incremento del 26%, Dove è finito
questo incremento Beh in pianura i
residenti sono aumentati dal 50%, in
collina del 22 in montagna Sono calati
del 10
da 51 quindi la gente è andata ad
abitare e a far figli dove la
concentrazione della popolazione la
semplicità Degli spostamenti favorisce
lo sviluppo di opportunità di grandi
fabbriche di grandi occasioni di servizi
infrastrutture perché perché le cose
costano meno la competizione fra
territori dunque ma soprattutto favorito
la pianura in seconda battuta La Collina
niente da fare invece per la poco
concorrenziale montagna più costosa meno
densamente abitata con spostamenti
difficili si erano impossibili Io sono
partito da Trento questa mattina il
navigatore mi offriva due possibilità o
arrivare direttamente attraverso le
montagne facendo 90 km impiegando due
ore e 50 oppure passare attraverso
Verona con l'autostrada impiegando
un'ora e 40
Dunque il principio dell'efficienza
economica nella componente più immediata
e percepita superficialmente che
assistiamo sistematicamente prevaso
nelle decisioni politiche di chi doveva
decidere dove favorire gli investimenti
e lo sviluppo lo Stato le sue emanazioni
la Anas le ferrovie ma anche le regioni
In altre parole fare cose in montagna
siano le sue scuole strade allevamenti
bovini o fabbriche costa di più
sia perché il territorio è più difficile
sia perché a causa delle difficoltà
della Difficoltà di trovare superfici
pianeggianti ampie è più possibile e
quasi impossibile concentrare e
avvicinare creare cioè le economie di
scala
a parità di popolazione ad esempio in
montagna servono più edifici scolastici
realizzare una viabilità adeguata costa
di più
sia come investimento che come
manutenzione della strada e poi i
trasporti finiscono in inevitabilmente
per essere più costosi
la popolazione dunque rinunciata alla
montagna perché sono state chiuse le
stalle
non più competitive con quelle di
pianura
ma anche perché le fabbriche non
arrivavano per la scuola superiore non
viene una ragionevole offerta e per
andare a teatro piuttosto che al
ristorante diverso dal solito
bisognava spendere troppo tempo ci
sarebbe tortuose e resi insidiose da
frane da ghiaccio
lo spostamento della popolazione Però
non è stata uguale in tutta Italia come
vedete dalla slide che adesso Dovrebbero
proiettarvi la perdita di popolazione è
stata minore lungo l'Arco Alpino
maggiore nel centro sud ad esempio in
Piemonte il calo è stato dell'11% in
Veneto del 15
ma nell'Emilia Romagna che anche più
ricca del Veneto è stato il 43
nelle Marche del 42 in Puglia
addirittura del 70
in realtà come il Veneto tutta la
montagna ha perso e continua a perdere
popolazione
comprese realtà con potenziali turistici
come l'altopiano di Asiago ma aperte
popolazioni anche la provincia di Rovigo
tutte in pianura ma lontano dalla
concentrazione dell'attività economica
che il Veneto ha deciso di concentrare
intorno all'autostrada Serenissima
ma vi è stato che anche chi ha visto
crescere la popolazione di montagna la
Lombardia più 22%
. è l'unica grande regione italiana con
un dato positivo frutto anche di un
passato di industrie collocate lungo le
Prealpi che hanno saputo reggere nel
tempo mantenendo un legame stretto con
il territorio
ma più è meglio di ogni altro hanno
fatto il Trentino la Valle d'Aosta con
un +36%, e poi l'altro oggi con un 55
Questi sono i dati dal 51 per Alto Adige
occorre ricordare che l'aumento della
popolazione è accaduto al rientro della
popolazione di lingua tedesca che se ne
era andata ed era fuggita disperata
durante il fascismo
da questo punto di vista Sembrerebbero
poter dire che
autonomia del centramento hanno un ruolo
importante
in realtà l'autonomia del centramento
sono una condizione necessaria Ma non
sufficiente
l'avvento delle regioni a statuto
ordinario ad esempio non ha cambiato il
quadro
le regioni che perdevano prima
dell'Avvento
dell'esperienza regionale hanno
continuato a perdere
e anche se prendiamo le tre grandi
autonomie speciali Sicilia Sardegna
Friuli vediamo che hanno perso tanto
quanto le regioni a statuto ordinario
quindi non c'è una grande differenza non
sono le istituzioni pensate che il
Friuli da 71 ha perso sette volte in
proporzione della popolazione di
montagna che ha perso il Veneto ed
autonomia speciale con Ampi poteri ampie
risorse e così via quindi non basta il
decentramento non bastano i poteri c'è
qualche cosa in più
e partiamo ancora una volta delle Tre
piccole autonomie speciali Valle d'Aosta
Trento e Bolzano
Perché queste hanno avuto questo aumento
così incredibile della popolazione
continuano a averlo
e Cosa spiega queste differenze tra
territorio però l'analisi econometrica
Individua due robuste evidenze la prima
nelle regioni dove la popolazione
complessivamente cresciuta di più
della montagna è stato meno intenso
In altre parole se la popolazione
aumenta su tutto il territorio regionale
una parte finisce per beneficiare anche
la montagna sotto forma di aumento di
popolazione come è venuto in Lombardia o
come minore perdita di popolazione come
avvenuto altrove
la differenza tra lui e il Veneto in 70
anni la popolazione del Friuli non è
cambiata
oggi il Friuli ha gli stessi abitanti
del 1951 Il Veneto è aumentato il 26%.
questo vi Spiega perché il Veneto da
questo punto di vista ha perso
popolazione di montagna ma molto meno di
quanto l'ha perso il Friuli lui è un
fallimento come autonomia speciale
la seconda
è ancora più interessante meno rilevante
la quota di popolazione di montagna del
più marcato lo spopolamento Cioè In
altre parole se come in Piemonte la
popolazione di montagna in proporzione
Maggiore rispetto alla pianura di quella
del Veneto a partire dalle altre
condizioni la montagna del Piemonte
perderà meno popolazioni di quella del
Veneto
della mutare della Puglia perdi 70 per
cento che il record Nazionale perché la
Puglia aveva anche il record nazionale
della minor quota di popolazione di
montagna l'uno per cento è letteralmente
sparita
quest'ultimo osservazioni portano a
riflettere a ragionare soprattutto a
questo punto in termini di istituzioni e
di rappresentanza
meno rappresentate la popolazione di
montagna negli organi politici più
prevalgono nella gestione gli interessi
e Le istanze della pianura
quindi la povertà della montagna
discende dal dominio assoluto che in
termini di voti di potere alla pianura
il principio è una testa un voto ha
finito per non tutelare una minoranza
come quella che vive in montagna
quindi
Quali sono le eccezioni a questa
evidenza la Lombardia
Ma perché la Lombardia è un caso a parte
è grande il doppio di qualsiasi altra
grande regione italiana e alla più
vecchia tradizione di industria e di
strutture economiche di tutta l'Italia
pensate più grande dell'Austria è una
storia che si perde lontano nel tempo
quando prendiamo invece in Valle D'Aosta
Alto Adige Trentino
perché il successo perché sono le uniche
tre realtà italiane in cui tutta la
popolazione di montagna
Quindi tutte le decisioni che vengono
prese non possono che essere
necessariamente a favore della
popolazione di montagna
si potrebbe argomentare che le tre
piccole autonomie Valle d'Aosta Trentino
Alto Adige quello di quelli veri sono
pieni di soldi
però attenzione C'è un aspetto che non
viene considerato il meccanismo di
finanziamento dell'Autonomia speciali
aggancia le entrate
allo sviluppo delle imposte e in ultima
analisi lo sviluppo economico
se un territorio cresce economicamente
crescono le entrate e la possibilità di
spendere c'è un territorio non cresce
economicamente o cresce meno di altri
come il Friuli o la Sicilia le entrate
in proporzione calano
Quindi da questo punto di vista Trento
Bolzano
e la Valle d'Aosta investendo sulla
montagna sono riuscito a mettere in atto
un modello di sviluppo economico che ad
esempio fa sì che il Trentino se il
territorio italiano che ha avuto la più
alta crescita economica del 70 giorni
nostri
Allora da questo punto di vista
Se guardiamo invece cosa è successo
Sicilia Friuli e Sardegna la Sicilia
aveva ancora più poteri del Trentino non
ha combinato assolutamente nulla
quindi non è l'autonomia non sono i
poteri e la cultura che determina i
risultati
e poi c'è l'ideologia
pensiamo e Facciamo riferimento ad una
ad un caso recente il piano nazionale di
rinascita e resilienza il PNR
sulla sanità ha deciso di innovare
rispetto al modello di sanità
territoriale
prevedendo il finanziamento
l'istituzione degli ospedali di comunità
e delle case di comunità per intenderci
sul territorio ci saranno ogni 40/50.000
abitanti delle strutture con medici
infermieri aperte 24 ore al giorno 365
giorni all'anno
qualche cosa che noi non abbiamo mai
visto neanche immaginato
come sono state finanziate le regioni in
base al numero degli abitanti
quindi Paradossalmente vi Cito un
esempio
la Lombardia e la Sardegna
la Sardegna al territorio più ampio di
quello della Lombardia ed è un'isola ma
un milione e mezzo di abitanti la
Lombardia 10 milioni di abitanti
e alla fine grazie a questo meccanismo
di finanziamento la Lombardia avrà sette
volte le case di comunità degli ospedali
di comunità che ha la Sardegna
E che cosa accadrà la montagna
è un principio stupido di eguaglianza e
prescinde dai bisogni dei territori in
questo senso
il prevalere degli interessi della
pianura garantita dalla Maggiore
rappresentatività numerica dei
parlamentari dei consiglieri regionali
si è tradotta in una sottovalutazione
del problematiche legate alla montagna
nel sistema elettorale del Veneto ad
esempio
il consigliere regionale che rappresenta
le montagne sono due quelli della
provincia di Belluno
su 51
e in provincia di Verona
gli abitanti di montagna sono 36.000
quelli che avete in pianura sono quasi
un milione
come se ne esce come si può tutelare la
montagna in un contesto dove In termini
di potere conta poco Beh una prima
soluzione lo dico un po'
provocatoriamente potrebbe essere quella
di creare con legge elettorale unici per
la montagna ad esempio se tutte le zone
di montagna del Veneto diventassero un
collegio elettorale unico il consigliere
regionale sarebbero 5 e non solo due
come oggi avviene
l'altra alternativa è fare delle
comunità montane un livello di governo
dotandolo di risorse di poteri che oggi
non ha
c'è un'alternativa sia affidarsi al buon
cuore della pianura
come è avvenuto fino ad oggi
con quali prospettive Beh c'è qualche
cosa che sta cambiando
La siccità di quest'estate e le
alluvioni sono cominciando a far capire
alla pianura che una montagna
abbandonata Non è neanche nel suo
interesse Speriamo altrimenti la
montagna sarà perduta per sempre grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]